et notre invité politique ce matin c'est
françois de rugy bonjour si beaucoup
d'être avec nous députés la république
en marche de loire atlantique vous êtes
également le président de la commission
spéciale à l'assemblée nationale sur la
loi séparatisme la loi confortant les
principes républicains et vous êtes
ancien ministre de la transition
écologique beaucoup d'actualité avec
vous aujourd'hui on est ensemble pendant
20 minutes pour une interview en
partenariat avec la presse quotidienne
régionale représenté par creissels
bertrand du groupe la dépêche
roh cristal bonjour bonjour bonjour on
commence par la crise sanitaire et ce
vote hier de l'assemblée nationale qui a
donc voter jusqu'au 1er juin la
prolongation de l'état d'urgence
sanitaire est ce le jour même où olivier
véran dit que finalement 1re confinement
ne sera peut-être pas nécessaire est ce
qu'il n'ya pas là un signal
contradictoire qui est envoyée est-ce
qu'il n'aurait pas mieux valu écouter le
sénat allait uniquement jusqu'au mois de
mai et refaire discuter le parlement à
ce moment là non je crois que il est bon
que nous adaptions le cadre juridique
dans lequel nous travaillons pour gérer
cette crise et qui évidemment ce cadre
juridique personne ne pouvait prévoir
qu'un jour nous devrions faire face à
une crise sanitaire de ce type
donc le crâne johnny ce n'est pas adapté
et c'est pour ça qu'il faut voter une
loi vous savez d'ailleurs que le
gouvernement avait envisagé d'avoir une
loi qui durablement permettre de faire
face à la crise personnellement j'aurais
préféré d'ailleurs que l'on ait ce cadre
durable plutôt que d'être obligé de
rejeter tous les 3 mois ou tous les six
mois
bon c'est plutôt d'ailleurs à la demande
d'un certain nombre de parlementaires de
l'opposition que le gouvernement a
finalement préféré c'est vote régulier
on ne va pas revenez la même chose tous
les mois ou tous les trois mois ça n'a
aucun sens ce qui compte c'est qu'on
puisse prendre des mesures rapidement
quand c'est nécessaire et pour cela il
faut un cadre juridique qui soit
efficace
vous entendez ce que dix sénateurs et
certains députés c'est vous avez été un
ancien président de l'assemblée
nationale c'est que le parlement n'ait
pas suffisamment consultés sur ce sujet
de la crise sanitaire qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
non mais il ya deux choses différentes
au jour le jour c'est normal que ce soit
le gouvernement qui dirige les services
de l'état qui se prennent les décisions
et qui les prennent rapidement c'est ce
que souhaite tout le monde pas
simplement
les élus je pense que les français
souhaitent que on puisse faire face
rapidement à la crise sanitaire on voit
bien que on suit au jour le jour semaine
après semaine
l'évolution du nombre d'hospitalisations
si on voit par exemple qu il va ya voir
qu'il ya un risque d'hôpitaux débordés
il faut prendre des mesures rapidement
on ne peut pas dans ces cas-là
enclencher un processus législatif ce
serait beaucoup trop long et puis par
ailleurs il y à la question de
l'adaptation de notre cadre juridique et
ça je pense que dans beaucoup de
domaines dans un autre domaine celui du
télétravail tout le monde sait que le
télétravail c'est une des solutions pour
réduire les contacts et donc réduire les
risques de contamination
et bien aujourd'hui le cadre juridique
français ne permet pas d'obliger les
entreprises à faire le télétravail si un
employeur ne veut pas faire du
télétravail
on ne peut pas les imposer si un salarié
d'ailleurs ne veut pas faire du
télétravail dans son entreprise sauf à
ce qu'il y ait un accord et c'est bon et
bien ça peut-être que ce sont des choses
qu'il va falloir adapter dans la loi et
ça c'est le travail du parlement
on va parler d'un autre sujet sur lequel
le gouvernement a fait des annonces hier
c'est le sujet des violences sexuelles
eric dupond-moretti adrien takei asseoir
se sont dits favorables à ce que tout
acte de pénétration sexuelle entre un
majeur et un mineur de moins de 15 ans
soit désormais considérée comme un crime
il ya beaucoup de textes au parlement
qui sera examinée en ce moment dont
temps d'une députée socialiste qui sera
examiné à l'assemblée nationale la
semaine prochaine est ce que la majorité
doit voter ce texte
en tout cas voilà un exemple où il y a
un travail parlementaire depuis des
années et ça a commencé évidemment en
2017 pour la majorité actuelle mais il y
avait déjà eu des propositions de loi
des avancées législatives sous des
précédents mandats
un travail à l'assemblée comme au sénat
a d'ailleurs le sénat avait été
fortement critiqué brocardé d'ailleurs
sur les réseaux sociaux
il y a encore deux semaines le croit
sans doute un peu à tort parce que
évidemment on peut prendre les choses
sous un angle ou sous un autre ce sont
des sujets difficiles délicat ceux qui
conseillent de faire avancer nos lois
pour le dragage ont protégé les enfants
et les adolescents pour qu'on le sache
faire le sénat qui a voté une
proposition de loi
billon du nom de la sénatrice anne
billon qui criminalisent la relation à
l'âge de 13 ans pour vous cette c'était
un moindre ext en tout cas on voit bien
que et le sénat et l'assemblée nationale
et le gouvernement travaille avec les
associations avec des victimes pour
améliorer notre arsenal juridique qui
aujourd'hui n'était pas efficace pas
toujours efficaces pour protéger encore
une fois les enfants les adolescents
face aux agressions sexuelles parce que
ce sont des agressions de différents
niveaux et le code pénal
le traitement par la justice à évoluer
et doit encore évoluer pour que la
parole de l'enfant ou de l'adolescent
parfois devenus adultes des années après
puisse être entendue puisse être traitée
judiciairement et que les éventuels
coupables soient évidemment condamné que
n'échappe pas à la justice donc c'est
des changements assez important que
encore une fois les sénateurs les
députés et le gouvernement veulent
maintenant voter et du coup vous mettrez
cette proposition de loi d isabelle
santiago jeudi prochain nous allons voir
mais ce qui est sûr c'est que nous avons
toujours été ouverts un travail comme on
dit parfois trans partisan c'est pas une
question sur la question de la majorité
ou de l'opposition de la république en
marche du parti socialiste des
républicains si on peut se rassembler
sur ces sujets tant mieux on l'a fait et
sujet est ce que bill a raison pourquoi
ne pas voter les textes de l'opposition
qui existent mais encore une fois nous
allons voir le gouvernement a fait un
travail le ministre de la justice eric
dupond moretti a dit qu'il avait
consulté un certain nombre de gens et
d'ailleurs il n'a pas fait des grandes
annonces j'avais consulté je vais réunir
tout le monde
il l'a fait et ensuite il a dit voilà ce
travail nous permet d'envisager des
changements importants de la loi parce
que ce qui est envisagé ce sont les
changements très importants sur encore
une fois la protection des jeunes de
moins de 15 ans il faut se souvenir
d'une affaire qui avait défrayé la
chronique il ya quelques années où un
tribunal avait dit bah non finalement
pour une jeune de 14 ans je crois on ne
peut pas parler de viols etc et même on
avait dit on peut considérer qu'il ya eu
un consentement et autres alors que par
ailleurs le discernement
dindane adolescents d'une adolescente de
moins de 15 ans et quand même on le sait
souvent sous l'emprise d'un adulte vous
êtes pour une pénalisation spécifique de
l'inceste et une imprescriptible
l'imprescriptibilité sur
l'imprescriptibilité je crois qu'il faut
être
il faut vraiment faire les choses avec
beaucoup de comment dire
on a eu une réflexion à l'assemblée dans
le précédent mandat on a changé les
règles sur les règles de prescription
vite et on a rallongé les délais dans
tous les domaines d'ailleurs sur les
question des violences sexuelles et
notamment sur les enfants
il y a déjà des délais importants
puisqu'on considère que ça ne commence
qu'après 18 ans et cetera parfois il ya
la question de la révélation des faits
et c'est donc il ya différentes règles
qui ont déjà permis d'allonger on peut
encore le faire il faut quand même faire
attention
je sais que c'est pas facile à entendre
évidemment par des personnes victimes
mais c'est quand même pas toujours
évident ensuite pour la justice
d'établir des faits trente ans après
quarante ans après donc il faut trouver
le bon équilibre je crois que la
proposition du gouvernement qui est de
dire que lorsqu'il ya des personnes qui
commettent des actes sur plusieurs
victimes
et bien ce soit la prescription par
rapport à la dernière victime connue qui
puisse enclencher les enquêtes sur
toutes les victimes précédentes
et ça c'est extrêmement important
plusieurs avaient d'ailleurs été a voté
au sénat et le but c'est que la justice
passe et la justice
elle passe grâce à ce travail approfondi
denquête deux polices de juges de
magistrat puis les tribunaux et pas sur
les réseaux sociaux
qu'il y ait des révélations sur les
réseaux sociaux pourquoi pas encore
qu'il faut quand même faire attention
aux gens dont les noms sont jetés en
pâture des vindictes qui peuvent être
lancés
et ce n'est pas la justice la justice et
des procédures donc c'est normal qu'on
le fasse en prenant le temps et y
compris ici au sénat ou à l'assemblée
nationale on va parler de la loi qui m'a
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres traduction législative d'une
partie des propositions de la convention
citoyenne est ce qu'elle est vraiment à
la hauteur des ambitions écologiques du
gouvernement cette loi ce qui est sûr
c'est que c'est une innovation
démocratique sans équivalent déjà dans
l'histoire de france mais en europe
d'avoir 150 citoyens qui ont été réunis
dans une sorte d'assemblée citoyenne
pour travailler sur ce sujet du climat
d'ailleurs c'est moi qui lui ai lancé
quand j'étais ministre avec le président
de la république nous n'étions à peu
près que les deux seuls à y croire à
cette assemblée citoyenne de citoyens
tirés au sort nous avons été critiqués
de toute part d'ailleurs
évidemment le résultat n'est pas parfait
le résultat qui est sorti de cette
assemblée citoyenne
la transcription en loi n'est pas facile
beaucoup de mesures très particulière
qui rentre dans les détails qui
évidemment nécessite un travail
d'évaluation
donc évidemment le projet de loi va être
critiqué y compris par les citoyens qui
ont participé à l'assemblée citoyenne
c'est normal et en plus il y a eu la
crise sanitaire
la crise sanitaire qui est quand même
venu percuter complètement un certain
nombre de sujets majeurs de cette
convention citoyenne renoncer transport
écologistes est-ce que ça va assez loin
moi je voulais d'expérience évidemment
qu'on peut toujours dire ça ne va pas
assez loin mais ce qui compte c est ce
qu on traite les problèmes c'est pas les
symboles
je vois bien que un certain nombre de
nos opposants et notamment europe
ecologie les verts ils vont s'agiter sur
des symboles vous dira mais telle mesure
elle n'est pas exactement ce que la
convention citoyenne a prévu europe
ecologie les verts qui étaient contre la
convention citoyenne quand nous l'avons
créé du jeu c'est une manoeuvre pour
perdre du temps et puis maintenant qui
dit attention ce qui a été proposé par
la convention citoyenne doit être
strictement mis en oeuvre dans la loire
bon tout ça c'est de l'agitation ça et
moi j'ai passées en politique
oui c'est de la mauvaise politique parce
que c'est pas du débat politique de fond
sur les enjeux du climat mais moi j'ai
fermé par exemple quatre centrales à
charbon à la demande du président j'ai
enclenché mis en oeuvre accompagner les
territoires pour fermer les quatre
dernières centrales à charbon de france
on ne produira plus d'électricité en
france par le charbon à partir de 2022
aucun pays d'europe n'a fait cela dans
le monde ça devrait être la bataille
prioritaire de sortir de la production
d'électricité par le charbon
et bien ça que ce soit en europe
ecologie les verts où que ce soit un
certain nombre d'associations
il considère que ce n'est pas
intéressant
écoutez c'est ça qui permet de réduire
les émissions de gaz à effet de serre
qu'europe écologie les verts une partie
des 150 citoyens se disent déçus par le
contenu du projet de loi
première question est ce que cette
déception ne risque pas de
décrédibiliser l'initiative un peu
novatrice que vous décriviez tout à
l'heure de consulter des citoyens est-ce
que ce que mon avis ce qui a posé
problème dans la le résultat de la
convention citoyenne déjà la convention
citoyenne elle a écarté un certain
nombre de sujets par avance c'est son
choix
on lui avait laissé vraiment un champ
très libre de proposition et plutôt que
de se saisir très largement de tous les
leviers d'action pour le climat
elle a choisi par avance des dents
écartées certains notamment tout ce qui
était fiscalité écologique taxe carbone
on peut le comprendre parce que c'est
pas facile ensuite à assumer devant les
autres citoyens les 67 millions de
français pourtant tout le monde sait que
c'est un sujet majeur
ça aurait été intéressant 1150 citoyens
disent ballard la fiscalité écologique
s'est jamais agréable de payer les taxes
mais voilà comme on aurait dû le faire
non mais elle a écarté un certain nombre
de sujets majeurs et donc évidemment
ensuite elle s'est beaucoup focalisé sur
des points beaucoup plus technique et
beaucoup plus contraignant par la
réglementation la question de logement
notamment mais aller jusqu'à parler de
la publicité d'un certain nombre de
choses comme ça qui aujourd'hui sont
percutés par la réalité de la crise
sanitaire mois on peut pas faire comme
si entre l'avant et l'après crise
sanitaire rien ne changeait le secteur
des transports est en chute libre
l'aviation par exemple où on a dit il
faut taxer l'aviation mais l'aviation et
s'est effondré le transport aérien s'est
effondré partout dans le monde y compris
en france
même le transport ferroviaire le
transport en commun est en baisse donc
est-ce que ça on en tient compte
ou est ce qu on fait comme si de rien
n'était non non il faut continuer comme
si c'était une sorte de bible dont il
fallait indéfiniment psalmodier ce qui
est écrit dedans non il faut évidemment
tenir compte de ce qui se passe dans
cette crise ont posé par la convention
citoyenne c'était d'interdire les
trajets en avion là où le train mais
moins de quatre heures vous n'y est pas
favorable c'est lui mais c'est pas que
c'est pas une question favorable ou pas
favorable de toute façon le transport
aérien s'est effondré aujourd'hui la
question qui est posée partout sur tous
les territoires de france d'europe et du
monde c'est plutôt de savoir si un jour
ça va repartir
si on va pouvoir
avoir toujours une industrie
aéronautique sabah la convention
citoyenne c'est normal c'est pas me
prononcer là dessus quand elle a
travaillé c'était pas il n'y avait pas
la crise sanitaire
tous les travaux de la convention
citoyenne on était fini avant la crise
sanitaire
le rapport a été rendu en juin mais tout
avait été fait avant le mois de mars
2020 donc moi je veux bien qu'on dise ah
non il faut continuer à se focaliser sur
l'avion typiquement un symbole c'est un
symbole c'est pas le sujet pour le
climat aujourd'hui le sujet pour le
climat tout le monde sait très bien ce
que c'est c'est le chauffage dans les
maisons dans les bureaux les transports
et notamment la voiture les camions
voilà c'est ça les gros sujets
d'émissions de co2 et dans le reste de
l'europe la production d'électricité là
aussi en france il faut quand même le
dire
nous avons une production d'électricité
qui est bas carbone comme on le dit donc
toutes ces choses là il faudrait pouvoir
les regarder a simplement d'ailleurs
avec la convention citoyenne mais en
général et regardez d'ailleurs nos
résultats je note d'ailleurs que les
associations certaines
environnementalistes où nos oppositions
d'europe écologie les verts disent non
la baisse des émissions de co2 constaté
récurrentes 2018 2019
ah ben non ça compte pas mais pourtant
elle est supérieure aux objectifs que
l'on s'était fixés ça c'est ça qui est
important c'est les actions qui donne
des résultats on ne réglemente pas et on
n'interdit pas les vols en avion sûr
mais on peut le faire mais dans l'avenue
mais c'est ridicule pour l'avenir c'est
une loi mais pas d'accord attendez vous
croyez que le transport aérien va
repartir comme si de rien n'était en
2021 2022 pas c'est complètement absurde
de considérer ça on est engagé dans une
transformation du secteur des transports
qui est une transformation durable
d'ailleurs moi je me suis battu aussi il
ya deux ans pour la voiture électrique à
l'époque comme je n'ose pas le sujet là
les ventes de voitures électriques
d'école
le reste des ventes de voitures baissent
ce qui d'ailleurs va poser problème
évidemment pour l'industrie automobile
et les emplois dans l'industrie
automobile
donc c'est tout cela qu'il faut regarder
et si est plutôt d'appuyer les
transformations qui vont dans le bon
sens que de continuer à se focaliser sur
des symboles dont on parlait déjà il ya
trois ans il ya cinq ans il adhère
questions sur cette loi et christelle
alors une partie du groupe
la république en marche à l'assemblée
disent attention à ne pas être prise en
tenait justement entre europe ecologie
les verts
et une partie de la droite qui va dire
qu'on va trop loin et et on a dû
remettre en question comme vous le
disiez certaines mesures qui étaient
proposés par la convention citoyenne à
cause de la crise économique mais il
faut qu'on propose des avancées sur
d'autres domaines
le parti lui a proposé l'idée d'un
chèque l'alimentation qu'est ce que vous
en pensez
quelles pourraient être les avancées sur
d'autres domaines pourquoi pas prêt je
voyais et on peut créer des chèques
angel chèque énergie on a déjà des aides
au logement on a bon pourquoi pas avoir
des aides qu'ils soient sont la cible et
c'est à dire on dit clairement c'est
pour acheter des produits alimentaires
de qualité produits en france ou
produits régionalement
d'ailleurs bon voilà après ce qui compte
c'est quand même les transformations que
l'on réussi à conduire dans la durée sur
le secteur agricole
là aussi si vous écoutez europe ecologie
les verts
l'agriculture française c'est la pire du
monde c'est l'agriculture la plus
polluante c'est la plus mauvaise
nourriture quand vous allez partout dans
le reste du monde
on vous dit que la meilleure agriculture
au monde c'est l'agriculture française
les agriculteurs français sont font des
efforts en permanence
l'agriculture française et européenne
c'est l'histoire d'une transformation
permanente
autrefois pour produire plus c'était
vraiment ça l'objectif toujours produire
plus aujourd'hui c'est toujours produire
parce que derrière c'est l'activité
économique et c'est le revenu mais avec
une plus grande qualité en réduisant
l'utilisation des pesticides en
réduisant aussi d'ailleurs l'impact
carbone de l'agriculture et ainsi de
suite
en remettant de la biodiversité grâce
aux oeufs etc
bon ben ça c'est ça qu'il faut
encourager dans la durée parce que c'est
ça qui produit des résultats
ce qui compte c'est les résultats un
dernier mot sur cette question
d'écologie l'état a été condamné
récemment pour une action climatique est
ce qu'en tant qu'ancien ministre la
transition écologique vous vous sentez
une part de responsabilité dans cette
condamnation mais c'est surtout que je
l'avais dit à l'époque je le répète
aujourd'hui ce n'est pas dans les
tribunaux combes et sera les gaz à effet
de serre ça ça fait de l'agitation
médiatique tant mieux pour ce qu'ils ont
fait et voilà ils ont l'impression
d'avoir une victoire et après c'est le
tribunal qui va dire ah voilà quelle est
la politique que vous devez mener pour
baisser les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre non ce serait bien que les
associations elles
fasse des propositions concrètes par des
symboles ou pas des chiffres
complètement truquée quand je vois des
gens disent ah si on réglemente la
publicité dans tel domaine
on fera baisser les gaz à effet de serre
ils sont même capables de donner un
chiffre en millions de tonnes de co2 par
an c'est complètement ridicule ton est
rien tout ça c'est de l'agitation
médiatique non
en revanche quand on a nous porter le
choix par exemple de la taxe carbone de
la transformation du chauffage par
exemple y en a dans toutes les maisons
et les immeubles de france
on veut supprimer le chauffage au fuel
progressivement mais on veut le faire
ah bin là les associations ou europe
écologie les verts c'est quand je me
suis retourné j'ai vu personne personne
ballon parce que on est dans l'agitation
médiatique on est dans toujours la
protestation la condamnation
l'opposition la dénonciation
oui voilà on va dénoncer devant un
tribunal mais qu'est ce qu'on va
proposer et mettre en oeuvre qu'est ce
qu'il ya comme réalisation bah ça c'est
nous qui l'avons fait parce que encore
une fois quand on ferme les centrales à
charbon quand on enclenche la
transformation de l'automobile pour
avoir des voitures électriques ou des
voitures hybrides électriques
rechargeables
là on a des résultats durables pour
faire baisser les émissions de gaz à
effet de serre on va parler de la loi
séparatisme de la loire confortant les
principes républicains je le disais vous
êtes le président de la commission
spéciale à l'assemblée depuis dix jours
elle est examinée en séance à 1 en
séance avant il ya eu 55 heures je crois
de débats en commission
après tout ce travail comment vous
qualifier aujourd'hui les débats sur ce
texte la teneur des débats
je note que les débats sont plutôt
apaisé bien sûr il ya des divergences
c'est normal qu'elle s'exprime je tiens
à dire d'ailleurs à celles et ceux qui
nous regardent que toutes les opinions
s'expriment à l'assemblée nationale et
c'est très bien ainsi
c'est la fonction de l'assemblée
nationale veut vraiment très grande
diversité d'opinions sur ces sujets qui
touchent à la laïcité notamment mais ou
à l'organisation des cultes aux
associations à la vie associative
mais nous avons un débat respectueux
apaisé on nous avait promis que
l'assemblée allait s'enflammer que
la majorité allait se diviser voir se
fracturer or en réalité nous avons des
débats apaisé qui permettent d'envisager
plutôt un rassemblement large autour de
ce texte je souhaite d'ailleurs que leur
ascendance large au delà de la majorité
moi je trouverais ça très bien que des
hommes et des femmes de gauche ou de
droite puissent voter ce texte dans un
esprit justement de rassemblement autour
des principes de la république c'est le
titre exact respect des principes de la
république et je trouve ça très bien
d'ailleurs que ce soit ce titre qui
justement est un titre rassembleur c'est
ça l'objectif
aujourd'hui on a besoin de réaffirmer
les principes de la république et de
veiller de mieux veiller à leur respect
c'est l'objet de cette loi alors
justement les républicains critiquent
une impasse qui aurait été fait selon
eux dans ce texte qui le thème de
l'immigration
pourquoi ne pas l'avoir inclus au teil
parce que c'est pas un texte sur
l'immigration alors on en a déjà fait
dès le début du mandat
c'était gérard collomb qui était
ministre de l'intérieur et l'assemblée
nationale le sénat travaille aussi
l'assemblée nationale a voté un texte
sur l'immigration et c'est normal vous
savez on est obligé de voter
régulièrement des textes et des mesures
sur l'immigration parce que
l'immigration prend tout le temps des
formes nouvelles
là aussi c'est quand même un vrai débat
entre une partie de la gauche ou des
verts totalement irresponsables sur
l'immigration qui veulent jamais
maîtrisé rien du tout en matière
d'immigration
nous nous assumons qu'il faut maîtriser
mais en revanche on ne remet pas
l'immigration dans tous les textes que
l'on fait on a pris une mesure
d'ailleurs dans le texte il ya une
disposition pour évidemment refusé les
titres de séjour par exemple aux
personnes polygame nous avons eu un
débat d'ailleurs très intéressant sur
ont condamné les personnes polygame est
ce qu'il faut pas protéger les femmes
qui parfois sont victimes de mari
polygame voilà donc nous avons pris des
mesures bien cadrée sur le sujet mais ce
n'était pas un texte sur l'immigration
c'est pas un texte non plus anti
terroriste la russie nous avons fait des
textes et nous continuerons à prendre
des mesures antiterroristes
c'est un texte sur le respect des
principes de la république on va
peut-être parler de quelques articles on
pourra pas tous les balayer ils sont
nombreux peut-être l'article 21 sur
l'inscription à domicile cristal oui
donc une autorisation sera désormais
commencer par l'article 1 parce que
l'article 1 que nous avons déjà examiné
c'est l'article sur en étant à tous les
services publics y compris par exemple
les transports assurés par des sociétés
privées et des agents privés
la neutralité du service public la
laïcité le refus des signes religieux
ostensibles pour tous les agents du
service public
article 6 sur les associations qui
oblige a signé un contrat d'engagement
républicains pour toutes les
associations qui vont évidemment
s'engager à respecter des principes
justement ici ce n'est pas le cas on
pourra réclamer le remboursement des
subventions fernand l'article
aujourd'hui une partie de la majorité
dit ok ce texte est un peu passée sous
les radars de l'opinion publique à cause
de la crise sanitaire
il faut donc qu'il s'applique très
rapidement pour qu'on en voit les effets
comment très rapidement par exemple on
met en place cet article la barre déjà
moi je souhaite nous sommes ici sur
public sénat que nous puissions trouver
un accord avec le sénat avec la majorité
du sénat
je crois que c'est possible c'est
souhaitable et c'est possible évidemment
il faudra que les uns et les autres
trouvent le bon compromis mais si on
pouvait rassembler la majorité de
l'assemblée la majorité du sénat autour
de ce texte ce serait une très bonne
chose je trouve que c'est un bon signe
sur justement notre volonté partagée de
défendre la république l'application des
principes de la technique partout en
france dont dans chaque sujet et puis
ensuite ça permettrait une application
plus rapide
évidemment puisque si on a un accord
entre l'assemblée il sait de quoi il ya
peu de vélo texture rapidement vous
dites pas que le sénat à majorité de
droite va faire de ce texte un texte
politique
je crois que le alors d'abord qu'est ce
que vous appelez un texte politique
parce que c'est un texte politique bien
sûr mais je vois bien ce que voulait
dire un sujet d'opposition en politique
entre la majorité l'opposition de droite
mais aussi peut-être de gauche puisque
au sénat c'est laid mais les oppositions
de gauche et de droite qui sont très
très majoritairement représentés mais
non ce que je crois c'est que le sénat a
souvent eu par le passé une capacité
justement à s'engager sur les principes
de la république sur des réformes ou sur
des lois qui engage la société sur une
voie républicaine résolument
républicaine je crois que le président
du sénat d'ailleurs c'est souvent
exprimé dans ce sens et je salue son
engagement à la matière donc je souhaite
que cela permet de déboucher
je ne suis pas devin donc c'est pas moi
qui vais dire ça va se faire mais je le
souhaite et donc ça veut dire qu'il faut
il travailler une dernière question
peut-être sur les régionales creissels
oui vous parliez de vous avez beaucoup
parlé d'europe écologie les verts
durant cette émission
vous allez peut-être être candidat alors
dès lors des régionales ou n'avait rien
annoncé encore mais vous pouvez faire
une radio c'est ce matin non j'ai dit
chaque chose en son temps là nous sommes
évidemment sur le projet de loi sur le
respect des principes de la république à
l'assemblée la crise sanitaire fait que
je crois que les français n'ont pas
tellement l'athlète aux régionales et
donc nous ferons les choses en son temps
alors vous allez peut-être foot et
matthieu orphelin qui est un proche de
nicolas hulot
est ce que vous allez faire de cette
campagne la campagne de l'écologie a mis
des entreprises contre l'écologie
punitive un peu les marcheurs contre les
amish
est-ce que ça va être ça la sauver votre
formule je ne la reprends pas mais
surtout sur l'écologie
il ya bien d'autres sujets sur
l'économie sur le développement
économique sur la formation sur les
transports ça ce sont les compétences
des régions je pense que la majorité a
des choses à dire peut proposer aux
français que les régions travaillent
main dans la main avec l'état pour faire
face à la crise notamment pour
enclencher plus fortement la relance
économique
on verra qui est au rendez vous de la
relance économique parce que c'est vrai
que moi je le vois sur mon territoire
mais je crois que c'est partout en
france la même chose europe ecologie-les
verts c'est un peu les antilles tout
anti tout projet tout projet de
développement et ils sont
systématiquement contre c'est un réflexe
bon et puis par ailleurs moi je
développe une écologie qui soient
fondées sur la science
l'analyse scientifique des problèmes les
solutions fondées sur la science
l'innovation technologique qui ensuite
donne lieu à des développements
économiques avec les entreprises mais je
crois en effet que ça fait une grosse
différence avec ceux qui au contraire
ont en fait comme projet la décroissance
et qui donc refuse systématiquement et
les innovations technologiques et les
développements économiques qui vont avec
et merci beaucoup merci merci et bonne
journée il nous faut ce matin bonne
journée à vous de laisser leurs gardes à
une de la dépêche avant de se quitter
c'est roland 88 ans victime de squatters
qui est à la une de votre journal merci
creissels merci françois de rugy merci
on passe au club des territoires
la mutuelle nationale territoriale la
mutuelle des agents des services publics
locaux vous présente le club des
territoires angie acteurs engagés dans
la transition zéro carbone des régions
vous présente le club des territoires
[Musique]
la presse quotidienne régionale et les
télévisions locales vous présente le
club des territoires avec nous
aujourd'hui pour ce club dans quelques
instants
enfin aurel et bruno cautrès on parlera
avec eux de la question des violences
sexuelles éric dupond reytier adrien
taquet se sont dit hier favorable à la
crim n à la criminalisation de tout acte
de pénétration sexuelle entre un majeur
et un mineur de moins de 15 ans alors
que plusieurs textes sont examinées
actuellement au parlement
on parla également de la loi climat
présenté ce matin en conseil des
ministres elle est la traduction
législative des travaux de la convention
citoyenne la politique écologique du
gouvernement est elle à la hauteur on en
débattra on posera également cette
question en ligne ils fouillent les
présidents du département de la mayenne
il sera notre premier invité dans
quelques secondes il nous dira quel rôle
peuvent avoir les élus locaux en matière
d'écologie on suivra bien sûr comme tous
les jours l'actualité dans nos régions
sera à perpignan avec pierre mathis de
l'indépendant il reviendra sur la
réouverture des musées voulue par le
maire louis aliot mais nous commençons
comme tous les jours par notre reportage
à votre rencontre on passe la semaine en
haute savoie en deçà voir un actif sur
cinq travaille à genève en suisse les
travailleurs frontaliers ont été
fortement touchés par la crise sanitaire
mais vous allez le voir
plusieurs dispositifs leur permettent
aujourd'hui de continuer leurs activités
plus sereine
[Musique]